and
action ready to have some fun please
stop
chanting is the TV okay and
cut this movie is about two
sisters and they have to come together
in a really crazy way to get one shy
sister on National Television to save
the thing that she loves the most your
Mom owes me 80 grand when you have it
you'll get your dog back my dog l you
know this game this is how you're going
to your dog this is synergy from the
universe oh my God I think I might have
manifested
this I hate all the words you just
used we have a very grounded emotional
story but there's a lot of physical
situations give me the keys No you want
to run I not run you I ran track what
you didn't run track I signed up for it
we had a ridiculously great cast working
it's prob working it's working
excitement and we're just pushing the
boundary of the the
humor that was incredible you almost
knocked my bow tie off I would have felt
quite nude I love will frell so much he
plays the host of this game show that
Anne has grown up watching and in a way
he's a father figure for her welcome an
thanks Dad I'm sorry what it's a really
cool pairing they're both really good
actors they both know comedy I think
it'll be a fun surprise for audiences
the Wardrobe for this movie is a lot of
sweater sets I was wearing loafers and
you could hear me from a mile away click
blacking the quality the heart and just
the funniness was all there at the very
beginning seeing the script come to life
was amazing it was so much fun I hope
that's what people
[Music]
[Applause]
feel